[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times just search Matt
Mullenweg tequila Ferriss for quite an
exciting time whether you're looking to
create a personal blog a business site
or both you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google shall remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that therefore 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
wordpress.com forward slash tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you so learn more take
a look
wordpress.com forward slash tim for
fifteen percent off a brand new website
check it out this episode is brought to
you by for sigma deck
you might remember for sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective in calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if too much of headache don't
worry and they are always game for
experimentation and so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
and or nut milks such as almond milk and
quote so I'm gonna say no you should
suck it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not
that bitter and maybe should take the
advice of all Chinese people when
they're criticizing young uns when they
say boo and I'm sure to cool which means
you're not able to eat bitterness bitter
is in many cases an indication of things
that help liver detoxification and so on
not saying that's the case here but I've
tested this ratio later on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and no don't put in honey or a nut milk
or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like poo air that kind of stuff
that type of tea you're gonna dig it so
just try it okay back to then my read if
you'd like to naturally improve your
sleep both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic
fueled mint extract organic rosehips
extract organic Tulsi extract and that's
it
no fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit anything so check it out
go to four sigma tech comm forward slash
ferrous and get 20% off this special
batch I don't know if they're gonna be
making much more of this since it was
made specifically for you guys so do me
a favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI GMA t IC comm /e
ferrous f e RR ISS and get 20% off the
special batch and you must use the code
ferrous to receive your discount fer AR
ISS so again go to 4 Sigma 2 comm
forward slash ferrous and then use code
ferrous for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners
enjoy
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job each
and every episode to deconstruct
world-class performers experts from
various disciplines across all
industries and today we have Brandon
Stanton who is the creator of the
number-one New York Times best selling
books
humans in New York humans of New York
stories as well as the children's book
little humans of New York in 2013 he was
named one of the 30 under 30 people
changing the world by Time magazine
Brandon has told stories from around the
world in collaboration with the United
Nations and was invited to photographed
President Obama in the Oval Office his
photography and storytelling blog humans
of New York has followed by more than 25
million people plus me on several social
media platforms he's a graduate of the
University of Georgia and lives in New
York City you can find his work on
Instagram at humans of NY as in New York
on Facebook humans of New York humans of
New York calm and a video series based
on the blog recently became one of the
first pieces of original content
acquired by Facebook so you can find
that as well humans of New York the
series Brandon
welcome to the show thanks Tim I really
appreciate you making the time and I've
been following your work for quite a few
years now and I'm excited to have a
chance to to pick at some of the earlier
days and explore questions that have
been on my mind for a few years now so
the the the first question I wanted to
take a stab at is actually one of
borrowing from another Georgian and that
is Joe Gebbia the co-founder of Airbnb
who likes to ask this question do you
remember the first time you got in
trouble or one of the first times you
got in trouble the first time I got in
trouble or a notable time that you got
in trouble when you were young a notable
time I remember I was sitting in my
used to take us to the grocery store a
lot of times after school and and you
know she was just gonna run in for a few
minutes and grab something and so we
were just supposed to sit in the car um
and I think I was like you know 9 or 10
um and I wasn't supposed to touch
anything but there were all these like
buttons on the dashboard and things like
that and um I remember she came back out
and I think you know the alarms going
off and then the keys the steering
wheels locked and and you can't move the
car and I remember that one very vaguely
because I wasn't allowed to go to the
Fall Festival at the school that year
which was a my favorite thing to do cuz
they had like carnival you know games
and things like that so going back in my
mind about the you know a painful early
time of getting in trouble you know that
comes into mind as I was doing homework
for this conversation I was reading up
on some of the suppose earlier days and
the particular sense that I wanted to
explore was in a previous interview of
yours and it covers quite a bit but it
said after having flunked out of college
and later going back and graduating as a
history major with straight A's and then
it goes on to say a number of other
things but did you get into a lot of
trouble as a kid or what what led to the
flunking out of college right well I
mean I always say that you know a lot of
my early trouble was coming from this
thought that I had to do something
really big in the world and you know I'm
sitting in class all day and I'm
learning these kind of you know very my
new details about things like the Magna
Carta and you know the compromise of 18
and none of this really seemed important
at all because you know I felt that I
felt that I was you know my purpose had
to be much greater than this and then
how am I going to use any of this in
life
and so like you know I spent all of my
time you know back then I was smoking a
lot of weed um and just like trying to
think about what my big idea and what my
contribution to the world was going to
be and instead of going to class I was
doing that you know instead of really
kind of working to improve myself you
know I was doing that just you know
pontificating and then just like
thinking all the time about you know
what my contribution to the world is
going to be and that was the time that I
flunked out and you know things really
started moving forward for me was when I
threw in the towel
you know I waved the white flag I said
you know I'm gonna stop trying to figure
out you know what the big thing I'm
supposed to accomplish is and I'm just
going to start doing what I was supposed
to do and you know I started riding the
bus and and started going to Community
College Georgia Perimeter College I got
my grades back up I went back to the
University of Georgia where I flunked
out of and you know I focused on
becoming a disciplined person and you
know having a routine in my life of
working out every day playing piano
every single day doing my homework and
you know it's funny because when I
stopped trying to think about this big
thing that I was going to accomplish in
life and started just focusing on
putting one foot in front of the other
every single day it began to propel me
on the journey that ultimately led to
humans of New York which was something
bigger than I could have ever imagined
when I was hitting the bong and the
Creswell dorm at the University of
Georgia
[Music]
now this preoccupation that you had with
your big contribution to the world
I don't know how common that is I didn't
have that occupation did you did that
come from parents did that come from a
book you read and where did that come
from
mushrooms might have had a little
something to do with it I can see that
it's just like I spent so
much time you know I had a very
intelligent group of friends and you
know so much of you know my 16 17 18 19
20 um was just I guess partaking in
these recreational activities trying to
figure out what is truth you know like
what is what is the meaning of all of
this and like all of these kind of big
questions compared to which you know
these intricacies of things like
calculus and algebra and you know verb
conjugations and French and you know all
these subjects something's being forced
to do in schools seem so minor and not
useful and - what I really wanted to
understand and you know alongside these
kind of like big questions about you
know why are we here and and what is
this all about kane this kind of feeling
and you know I think some sort of kind
of vague spirituality was wrapped up in
it as well that you know this is a this
this world is so amazing and the fact
that we're here is so amazing and doing
anything less than something amazing is
kind of squandering you know this this
whole reason that you're here um and I I
think that's that was the kind of
thinking you know that brought me down
this path that I was you know my time
was too good and and in my thoughts like
you know the the space in my brain was
too precious to you know fill it up with
all these you know little this homework
and this and this stuff that seems so
unimportant uh and so instead I just you
know spent all my time just kind of
grappling with these with these bigger
things what was it like growing up in
Marietta Georgia am i right
visa agree and were you born in Georgia
also yeah I was born in Georgia I mean I
am somebody who has
liked everywhere I've ever been I liked
my school I liked my college I liked the
community college I went to after I
flunked out of my college I liked
Atlanta I like Chicago I Love New York
you know I'm generally somebody who
appreciates the the place that I'm in I
tend to find that people complaining
about where they live not always I mean
it's not you can there's always some
place that you can be that might be
better for you but if you hate the place
that you live if you if you kind of just
despise it
um I find that a lot of times a new
environment is not the key to your
happiness because I find a lot of times
the people that are complaining about
one place when they move to another
place then you know if it's if they live
in Atlanta and the answer is New York
then when they get to New York you know
what New York's dead
the answer is LA when they get to LA the
American values suck need to get to
Paris you know when they get to Paris oh
you know the West is is so you know it's
so materialistic I need to go to India
you know what I mean so I find a lot of
times the place that kind of the people
who kind of externalise their
environment as being the reason for
their dissatisfaction tend to be
unsatisfied everywhere I'm kind of the
opposite you know I've loved every place
that I've lived I love the people um you
know that I've met in every place I
lived Marietta was Starbucks and Barnes
and Noble but I had a great great group
of friends and you know I enjoyed
growing up there this time just piecing
the connective tissue together as I go
because I'm really interested I don't
know why this is the case but it
particularly last six months I've been
more and more fascinated by the earlier
stages with almost everyone I've been
chatting with the history major you
graduate with straight A's and then you
end up and I know you've you've spoken
quite a bit about this we won't belabor
the point but you get a job as a bond
trader in Chicago is my understanding
and it was Smurf that write the
first time that you weren't embarrassed
in front of family and friends about
where your life was going you get this
this prestigious job how do you how did
you go about choosing that job or
finding that job or how do they find you
from history right right so I mean the
whole reason I became I'm going to give
you to catch you up a little bit um you
know when I first went to the University
of Georgia I was majoring in business
that's when I wasn't going to class I
flunked out and then when I decided to
go back to college you know I thought to
myself well I'm just going to study
something that I enjoy anyway so it's
not this kind of you know major force of
effort to go to class and to do my work
at that time I had developed a reading
habit that was really when my life kind
of turned around so remember you know I
I I stopped thinking about these kind of
big problems I wanted to solve and you
know I started focusing on you know
establishing a routine some discipline
in my life and one of the first big ones
and still probably the most monumental
routine that I ever established and
decision I ever made was that I was
going to read 100 pages a day mostly
nonfiction and whether the book was the
little prince or it was something like
The Wealth of Nations you know whether
it took me an hour or whether it took me
eight hours every single day I was going
to read a hundred pages and I did that
for years even when I went back to
school in addition to my schoolwork I
would read a hundred pages what Kant was
sorry to interrupt but what catalyzed
that decision I mean was there a feeling
it's like this it was this feeling I
mean psychologically you know it was
like this feeling of being you know
maybe behind you know I remembered I
remembered um you know the one of the
very first books that I read was this
autobiography of you know Ben Franklin
and you know he has all these kind of
you know he did the Poor Richard's
Almanack and he has all these kind of
sayings and I remember you know first of
all Ben Franklin himself was kind of the
pioneer in in getting self-improvement
down to a science don't know what I mean
and um so you know his example first of
all of how much he you know how much
effort he put into improving himself and
moving himself forward and then I
remember he had this one quote you know
that uneducated genius is like finding
silver in the mine you know and it kind
of it you know made me think that you
know I had spent all this time kind of
you know thinking and kind of pondering
uh and I thought that I was you know
that school was beneath me and school
was boring and you know because of that
I really hadn't been imbibing much
information and you know at that time
it's something kind of flipped and I
felt like you know I've missed out on
you know probably the last four or six
years of education because I was just
doing the minimum you know I was I was
just getting by and writing my papers
before class you know I was probably
looking at the person who's next to me
he's paper you know a few times and so
it's like even though I was making ok
grades I really wasn't you know taking
in a lot of information and educating
myself and so you know I think that at
that time I decided I was going to
become extremely educated and you know I
did I did become an extremely educated
person but you know 95% of that
education was outside of school you know
95% of that education was over the
course of seven or eight years saying
I'm going to read one hundred pages of
nonfiction a day every single day and I
did it for seven or eight years I'd say
60% of that was biography I would say
another 20% of it was history and then
you know I'd and that wasn't I would
read fiction too you know when I was
absolutely tired of eating my vegetables
that's what I that's what I would call
you know the most boring books you know
the really kind of conceptual one I just
viewed as vegetable so you know it's
just like with some sometimes the fiber
of knowledge yeah
you know but it grows and it kind of
develops you um but yeah you know so
biographies were the ones that I was
really really drawn to and so you know
at the time you know I started like kind
of reading all these biographies and I
was loving it and biographies is history
you know biography is the best form of
history if you ask me because it it cuts
through the theory it cuts through you
know all the speculation of the author
and we get down to the nuts and the
bolts of the decisions that people made
in their lives and I think that is the
purest form of Education that you can
get and it is the advice that I give
people who don't know what they want to
do with their lives pick somebody that
you admire and read their biography read
their biography if you really want some
sort of guidance in your life pick
somebody who's done things that you want
to do and that you really admire and
read a nice fat 800 page biography of
their lives find out the struggles they
went through find out that you know the
twists and turns of their lives and the
decisions they made and I mean I don't
think there's any better actionable
roadmap actionable education than
getting down in the granular level of
somebody's life and finding out how they
navigated it if if someone wanted to
let's just say that they are having a
lapse of concentration and can't think
of people they admire who have
biographies if you were to recommend any
let's just say 1 2 3 biographies as
gateway drugs into that world there any
that come to mind it depends upon what
you want to accomplish in life like if
you're just flagging and you don't know
what you want to do start with Ben
Franklin start with somebody who is who
is you know very disciplined and you
know programmatic and in figuring out
how to develop themselves again my
advice always to people who are stuck is
quit looking at the big picture as
people get stuck because they want to
accomplish too big of things and they
don't know the right step to take so you
know I always say just kind of instead
of focusing on the year instead of
focusing
on the arc of your life focus on the
24-hour period and nobody mastered the
24-hour period more than Benjamin
Franklin so it's like if you have no
idea what you want to do start there I
would say if you know what you want to
do you've got to pick the person that
you admire the most you know do you want
to participate in social movements you
know pick Martin Luther King do you want
to be President of the United States if
you want to pick be President of the
United States I would recommend Lyndon
Johnson Lyndon Johnson because he was
probably the president that was given
the least in his life except for maybe
Abraham Lincoln you know he was the
pretty he didn't go to Ivy League you
know he didn't um he wasn't necessarily
a a great-looking guy you know he went
to San Marcos teacher College he you
know basically he if you want to be
President I don't want to be president
he you know worked his way up through
understanding how the levers of
democracy work the levers of power and
our government work and so he is a
fascinating character sketch on how to
be president if you want to read a
Lyndon Johnson biography you should read
the four volume biography by Robert Caro
which is the best of those um but you
know other than that it's just like it
all depends upon what it is that you
want to do in life you know there's
there's just no biography that every
person should read they should pick the
person they admire the most and read the
biography of their life with Ben
Franklin it would it be the a biography
like Walter Isaacson or would be the the
Isaac the Isaacson one was the one I
read and that stands out the most
because it was the first the person that
I've read the most biographies on
probably Theodore Roosevelt um just
because his life is so fascinating um
probably Adolf Hitler probably Stalin
and it's not because in any way these
people are admirable but like as a
history major to me it wasn't the
individual themselves that was
fascinating to
me it was how does a group of people you
know Germany was a smart industrialized
country to me the big philosophical
question that fascinated me in the end
the reason that I dealt so much into the
lives and and the practices of dictators
is you know how is it that a group of
such educated smart well-meaning people
we're able to be you know um ever to be
able to be organized under the you know
the premise of committing such evil and
that to me has has always fascinated me
because I believe that people are
inherently good and you know I've
traveled a 30 or 40 different countries
and you know it's funny every place has
a reputation oh don't go to this city
people won't talk to you
you have so many times when I land in a
place they say you know this isn't gonna
work here you know people people aren't
open here people aren't friendly here
and you know I find one-on-one people
all over the world you know are very
they they kind of share you know it is a
similar soul I guess and you know if
people are generally the same everywhere
you know then then that means anywhere
something like this could happen right
anywhere you know people can can get
pulled into this crowd psychology and
you know direct their anger in their
hatred and violence towards people in a
way that would countered it their morals
if you met them one-on-one and you know
because of that the the the lives and
the periods of history that have always
been most intellectually interesting to
me again it's not something I admire
it's not something I I'm looking that
duplicate of course have been these
periods where a very driven ideological
individual has managed to to mobilize a
group of people towards ends
that looking back from a historical
perspective were brutal and violent and
absolutely unexplainable and you know I
think it's important to understand these
things to keep it from happening again
do you remember you asked about bond
trading like oh I do I you know I
started talking about histories because
bond trading was really an anomaly in my
life um I was really kind of wrapped up
in all these things that were talking
about now you know I was really kind of
wrapped up in history and and biography
mainly um when Obama it was God what was
it 2008 2007 I think was 2007 he was in
the primary um and I was I really became
fixated on this campaign and you know I
was not I was going to knock on doors
and this was during the primary when he
was going up against Hillary and I was
knocking on doors I was going to
different states and knocking on doors
and and I was reading every article
about the the delegate system and
super-delegates and you know there was
this point where I was just absolutely
positive he was going to win I was this
is the primary oh it's just absolutely
positive he was going to win and I was
broke at the time this is not something
I would ever do today um but I took out
five thousand dollars in student loans
and I actually bet on Barack Obama where
does where does one bet on something
like that back then it was an Irish
exchange in a sense gone under it was
called in trade um and I think they had
him at like 40% chance to win at that
time um and he had like a 70% chance or
something and so you know I I didn't
make a ton of money off of it because it
took me like a week to wire my money to
Ireland and in the time that I was
wiring my money he had won a couple of
the odds changed exactly and so
you know I ended up only me I mean I
made like Dino a thousand twelve hundred
dollars which for me as a college
student was all the money in the world
but more faithfully I was telling that
story just like I'm telling it to you to
a friend of mine who worked in Chicago
and he was a trader he was a bond trader
and I was telling I was telling him that
story and he told me you know the the
one differentiator between successful
traders and unsuccessful traders in our
office is their own their comfort with
risk-taking and based on that story um
you know I would like you to talk to my
boss based on the extreme prudence
you've demonstrated that story time I
was you know I I didn't know what I
wanted to do again I just studied
history because I was ill enjoyed it and
nice and I really enjoyed it um and so
he got me in an interview with his boss
and it was scheduled and I mean this is
somebody who went to an Ivy League
school and you know he had studied
finance his entire life and he had
gotten this job so I thought this was an
opportunity I would not have any other
way and I wasn't sure what I wanted to
do at the time I was a history major um
and so I had like a month to prepare so
I read about 20 books on the market and
then I went into the interview and at
that time I was very well versed on how
markets worked and that's how I got that
job good thing you had all that reading
practice go what was your first week as
a bond trader like um well I mean see
this is the and I always try to say you
know when I just listened to this
interview up until this point you know I
think it's we talked about you know bond
trading and dictators you know
which really has nothing to do with my
life now um but you know I and I think
the narrative that people in interviews
always try to put on me is that because
I mean it's a fun narrative Oh chasing
the money you know doing this
soul-sucking finance job and then you
know cut the rope behind him to pursue
his true passion which was taking
photographs it's an art and I mean
there's a there's a kernel of truth
there um you know but the the real story
is that markets were fascinating to me I
you know I I'm still fascinated by
markets you know they seem so tangible
when you're watching CNBC and you're
seeing these numbers and it seems also
mathematical but in reality markets are
nothing but a bunch of people arguing
over what something's worth you know
it's just like it's a a market if you if
he removed the computer and you know go
back you know 50 years and market is a
crowd of people haggling over what's
something that is impossible to value is
worth and the the number that comes out
of it is is really based on psychology
and it's based on this this back and
forth over over you know what these
numbers mean and you know that was
always so interesting to me um and it
remains you know very interesting to me
so I was philosophically very interested
in markets and I was I I was fascinated
by bond trading and you know I I was
obsessed with it to be honest for two
years um and it was a type of bond
trading we were very highly leveraged
and so you know it was a type where
there was just huge gains or huge losses
like every single night you know I
compared it to like playing very
high-stakes game of poker every single
night and so it was it was extremely uh
you know I don't think I could do it
today I was in my early 20s at the time
it was just there was just adrenaline
pumping through my body at all times and
you know I was in in that when you
when you take something that is your
you're naturally kind of philosophically
interested and you pair it with um you
know a large amount of money and a large
amount of excitement it creates this
this fixation it's almost like crack you
know where it's just all you can think
about at any given time and you know
when I go to colleges and I give
speeches on you know the path of humans
of New York and you know what led me to
kind of pursue this life that was you
know outside of books and outside of
computer screens was that you know I
after the end of two years when I lost
my job I kind of looked back at you know
the time that I had spent that two years
and it it wasn't the physical time that
was lost that was most concerning to me
it was that I had spent two years using
all of my intellect and all of my
creative energy trying to figure out how
to be the most effective relative value
trader and fixed income securities in
the Asian markets it was something it
was just something that was so narrow
and so myopic and I couldn't even talk
with my friends about it and at the end
of two years you know that was we've
gone through the financial crisis I'd
lost everything I'd ever made you know
when I when I lost that job was a very
lucrative job potentially but when I
lost that job I was broke because I'd
lost everything why did you lose the job
what happened uh well I mean the it
depends upon how much personal
responsibility I want to take you know I
think the the the narrative that's most
protective of the ego is that we had a
type of trading that was calibrated to
work during periods of low volatility um
the years from I guess 1995 or whatever
or after the whenever you know I don't
know when my math is right but you know
like Leighton
these two you know 2008 were periods of
historically low volatility where the
type of trading that we were doing
worked and during when the financial
crisis hit in 2008 volatility went
through the roof long story short the
type of trading that we were doing um
stopped working and the company when
that had been around for over a decade
was out of business about a year after I
left so that's the that is the the part
of the that that's the way of explaining
that that avoids the most personal
responsibility if I was to explain it in
the way that you know makes myself the
most personally responsible
markets changed and I wasn't adaptive
enough to figure it out
I kept banging my head against the same
things that used to be working I refused
to I refused to fully embrace the fact
that what worked for me extremely well
for a year had stopped working and
because of that the the the risk
calculations had changed and instead of
making a lot of money every night I was
losing a lot of money every night and I
eventually got to the point where you
know I I was no longer a productive
member of the firm uh
and so yeah depends upon which story you
want to tell I think the truth is
probably somewhere in between the two
but regardless I ended up without a job
well thank you for telling or sharing
both versions of that and know it's it's
it's I think that that also reflects a
level of this may not be the right word
but sort of objectivity or ability to
detach and observe that has always
fascinated me about you quite frankly
which certainly translates I think in a
very empathic way later and we'll get to
that but I want to talk about the
finance world and markets for just a
second because as you noted it's it's
very tempting for someone who's trying
to weave a narrative
of your life into this soul-sucking
period sees the light cuts the tether
burns the ships off into the arts and
true passion but the the markets as you
noted are really fascinating and I was
chatting with someone I've just gotten
to know actually in the last few weeks a
let's call I suppose you could call him
a wealth manager but 75 percent of what
he does is invest in in bonds he
probably wouldn't call it trading but in
effect I mean that's that's what he's
doing and he said something to me that
that is stuck in my mind for a while now
which is you know I learned more in the
first two to four hours of sitting down
and talking to someone about money than
their therapists have probably learned
over the last two to four years and
getting to see how people respond to
money and loss aversion and the
possibility of making money is in and of
itself fascinating then you add in
thousands and millions of market
participants it gets even more
interesting and then when at least in in
my limited experience when I read
something my exposure to bonds is very
limited but when you read something like
liars poker by Michael Lewis which i
think is a fantastic book and the part
that stuck out to me where I was like
okay I need to be very careful about
playing this game because I got my face
ripped off is there's some part I'm
gonna get all the details wrong but
there's some guy who's nicknamed like
Fat Tony and he's a bigwig at Salomon
Brothers and he bets his buddies that
the markets for whatever double-a bonds
and XY and z are going up and he bets
them and it's this dick-measuring
contest and he puts 50 million into the
market in it and he goes down and and so
his his friends are busting his balls
and he's and then I got markets going up
huh and so he instead of putting 50
million and he's like [ __ ] it he puts
five hundred million in like all the
other market participants panic thinking
that he has information they don't and
so the market goes up and he says see I
told you the market was going up and I
was like oh my god this is not nearly as
clean as the textbooks would want you to
believe well I would you know I had some
who's interviewed 10,000 people I would
say that you know talking with somebody
about their money and how they choose to
use their money will give you a insight
into a very limited a and I I mean maybe
maybe I'm wrong but like a very limited
aspect of their personality which is
their comfort with risk and you know I
think there's I think our approach to
money and our approach to trading and
are punched to to markets are very much
kind of driven by like our animal
spirits you know greed and fear and
things like that um but you know I feel
that the you know kind of the the
there's a huge a huge portion of
people's lives and kind of thought lives
that are you know kind of separate and
you know isolated from from that those
drives you know what I mean those those
very kind of primal drives of wanting
wanting more and being afraid to lose I
mean that's that's really what what
drives the markets is is that is the
greed and the fear is and I you know I
think I think talking you know with
somebody about their you know their
those those two drives and where their
greed comes from or where their fear
comes from you know it'll give you you
know it'll give you it'll give you some
insight but you know I they know to me
the the markets you know they there's
they can only tell you so much and they
can only you know it's such a it's such
a it's it's a part of human existence
the the the drives that that control a
market um but you know there's so much
that people care about outside of that
and I think that was what was so
dangerous about just being a trader is
that you know you're you're you're
burying so much of your thought energy
into just the desire for more and the
fear of losing you know what I mean that
kind of the kind of narrow animalistic
drives that that you know that that push
a market ups up and down and you're kind
of tethering yourself to that and you
just kind of miss out on so much of the
life that's going
on around you and this is me you know
this is me I think it's part of my
personality that once I dive into
something it's I do it to the exclusion
of almost everything else one of the
reasons humans of New York ended up
becoming so successful I didn't know you
know some you know miss more the
exception than the rule there are people
who are so in control of their emotions
or maybe they don't have the same
emotional range as other people um that
are able to turn off their computer
every single day go home and not think
about the markets and come kind of
completely leave them there um but you
know for me it was something that you
know was kind of all-consuming for me
and you know when I made the the
decision to pursue something more
artistic um was when you know I had kind
of I had kind of lost my job and I was
looking back at the two years of my life
and I was thinking God you know and and
after I lost my job you know I I was so
scared of that day you know during the
two years when I was obsessing over
markets and then things started going
bad you know there was nothing I was
more afraid of than losing that job and
then on the day that it happened it was
surprisingly a good day because I
remember taking a walk that day and I
started asking myself things like what
do I want to do you know like what do I
want to do things something like if I
could do anything with my time what
would I do and I had I had been for two
years like so focused on keeping that
job you know that I had didn't I
I had never I did have room in my brain
to kind of ask myself any other
questions and so you know at that moment
I decided you know I've lost these two
years not only my time but more
importantly I've lost two years of my
thoughts focusing on this this this game
this game for making money which was
fascinating and philosophically
interesting but you know when you when
you boil it down it's a game
and I said you know I'm gonna spend the
next foreseeable future instead of my
spending my time you know trying to to
make money you know I'm gonna try to
make just enough money to where I can
control my time and just do something
that I enjoy doing for no other reason
then it is nourishing in the moment not
that at the end of the day I'm gonna
have a profit but because it's
nourishing in the moment and at that
time it was photography and the whole
reason I think you know one of the the
best you know the kind of neatest things
about humans of New York is that over
the past eight years you know humans of
New York has become largely you know the
most you know followed photography
project in the world with you know they
think 25 million on social media now and
it's eight years old and I think one of
the coolest things is I just started
photographing about eight years ago you
know I started taking photos during this
time that I'm talking with you about and
the whole reason I started taking photos
was because I was trying to create some
space in my mind away from work I was
desperate for something to do on the
weekends that you know did that would
would give me this this foothold in my
brain worm I had a sense of purpose and
a sense of identity outside how the
markets were doing every single day and
so I bought this camera I started going
to downtown Chicago and photographing
you know just everything and I loved it
and not long after I lost my job and I
made the decision that I was going to be
a photographer
not because I was very skilled at it at
the time you know not because I thought
it was an angle towards success and not
because I thought it was an angle
towards an audience is that I just loved
doing it in the moment it was nourishing
in the moment and so I found this thing
that was nourishing in the moment that I
enjoyed doing and I said you know I'm
going to try to structure my life around
creating as much time for this as
possible I want to make the minimum
amount of I just I want to make just
enough money
to where I can pay my rent eat and
photograph all day long and the journey
that ended up creating humans of New
York was my attempt to create that space
in my life and that space in my head to
focus on something that was very
nourishing in the moment how did you
cover your expenses in the very early
days of that experience this was 2008 um
we had a I believe a record amount of
time that you could get unemployment and
I had just lost my job
and so I got six hundred and twenty
dollars I think every two weeks from the
government because I was unemployed and
I had worked for two years um so that
was enough to basically just pay my rent
in a sublease that I found on Craigslist
and bedford-stuyvesant Brooklyn that was
enough to pay that and maybe have peanut
butter jelly sandwiches and eggs um
assuming that you need to know other
expenses that you wore the same clothes
and the same shoes that was enough for
me to just eat sleep and photograph all
day long um and once I got to have a you
know a decent level of skill uh and I
mean just a passable level of skill if
anybody would pay me to take portraits
for them I would do that I somebody
hired me to do their wedding um and I
basically I just I I didn't spend money
on anything all I did was photograph all
day long because I knew that I was like
I was making this pivot in my life to
where I was going after kind of a
lucrative career towards I was going
towards just wanting to spend my time
doing something all day long and so you
know and I became obsessed with
photography in the same way that I was
obsessed with markets I mean I just
I loved it I just loved it it was like a
treasure hunt I mean just going out and
was so different than trading to I mean
it was I'm outside I'm interacting with
the world I'm having conversations you
know I'm having these little adventures
and discovering these new things and I
was just hooked on and I'm just obsessed
with it and you know I knew I was making
a lot of sacrifices to be doing this in
my life
so I didn't do anything else you know I
didn't go to concerts I didn't go out to
restaurants I really I didn't spend much
time with friends I didn't really know
anybody in New York I mean that's
another crazy detail about humans of New
York said humans in New York is an
eight-year-old photography project you
know based on people in New York City
you know I took my first foot photograph
eight years ago and I went to New York
for the very first time in my life eight
years ago so it was you know all it was
all just very new and all very driven by
the desire to photograph all day long
was the move to New York related to the
desire to take photographs or wasn't it
something else so I mean what I did is
so I got fired and I started my goal was
I gonna I want to find out how to be a
photographer you know I love photography
how am I gonna create a life where I can
support myself and photograph all day
long and so I was just out doing it
every single day and then I started kind
of along with the graffiti and along
with the you know architectural shots
and along with the nature shots I
started photographing people and I
noticed that these out of everything I
was photographing the photographs of
people were the most unique they're the
ones that that would least resembled
everything else I was seeing being put
on Facebook and stuff like that um and
so I decided to kind of focus on that
and then while focusing on that I
started stopping people on the street
asking for their photo and kind of
taking a portrait of them and because of
that extra layer of difficulty of having
to approach a stranger
the portrait so that was taking of
people were more different than the the
candid photos I was taking of people and
so I started focusing solely on that you
know and that's when I kind of started
having an idea that even though I hadn't
been photographing so long I was heading
in a direction that was pretty unique
because I was stopping random people on
the streets um in a very you know I know
some people will do series but I was
doing this every single day and I was
getting quite a collection and this
seemed like kind of a new kind of fresh
type of photography so it's all I did
and then I started traveling to
different cities I went to Philadelphia
just stopping people then I went to New
Orleans I went back to Atlanta and did
this and then I traveled to New York and
when I got to New York and I was
stopping people and asking for their
photographs um I realized that New York
if you were going to try to do this type
of photography was the best place to be
I mean mainly just just practical
reasons that you you don't need a car in
New York I didn't have a car um and I
couldn't afford a car yeah uh you can
just ride the subway everywhere you can
walk everywhere and there's so many
people I mean there's so many people I
remember coming out of the Lincoln
Tunnel the very first time and looking
down and I couldn't even see the
sidewalk that's Russia it was rush hour
and it was just there were so many
people and I thought you know if I'm
going to do this type of photography
this is the place to do it and I wasn't
doing any interviews at this time and I
mean that's that's the thing it's like
the humans of New York that I moved to
New York to do looks nothing like the
the humans of New York that later became
successful I mean it was really just the
impetus to get me on the ground working
every day to kind of figure it out along
the way you know my very first idea for
Hugh
of New York was I was going to
photograph 10,000 people in New York
City across all five boroughs and I was
gonna plot their photo on a map that was
my idea of how I was going to make a
life out of being a photographer so I
was gonna be the guy who did that and it
was that was kind of what got me on the
ground got me out on the streets every
single day approaching hundreds and
thousands of people and put me in the
situation where I could kind of innovate
and I could start having conversations
with these people which turned into
questions I was asking them which turned
into eventually seven years later the
kind of 90 minute to an hour and a half
long very kind of probing and
therapeutic and and psychological
interviews that I have with random
strangers every single day the result of
which and the output of which became the
stories that I think people are so
connected with and the stories that
really make humans of New York humans of
New York how are you getting better at
photography
because during this say first let's just
call it six-month period since you
certainly seem from all indications to
be someone who goes for Total Immersion
and whether it's reading 10 to 20 books
on the markets before an interview you
go a hundred percent into whatever
subject matter you choose how are you
getting better what books are you
reading who are you studying what are
you trying I mean I was too addicted to
taking photos to ever stop for a second
and learn about photography I have I
have one memory I have one memory of
going to Barnes & Noble because I can
afford to buy any books I have one
memory of going to Barnes & Noble one
night and flipping through some
photography books and and enjoying the
photos but I just I I just wanted to be
out taking pictures you know I didn't
really
want to be studying how to take a
correct photo you know I just wanted to
be out photographing it was the the act
of it the act of discovery you know and
I had a very amateur view of photography
at the time where is if you if you get
something or somebody interesting in the
frame it's a great photo I don't care
how many points perspective it has I
don't care about the rules of thirds I
honestly don't really even care about
white balance or focus or any of these
things I was just looking for for
wonderful people and wonderful moments
that were happening I was still doing a
lot of candid photography of people and
if I captured that that was a good photo
and that's that's all I cared about and
that was what was driving me for these
you know these first several months and
this first year year and a half when I
took thousands and thousands of pictures
and I was getting better slowly I mean
I'm I'm I'm not necessarily bragging
about that kind of aversion to formal
training as if it was some sort of badge
of honor it was just the way my
psychology was hardwired and because of
that I might have improved more slowly
than somebody else and in fact I might
have improved so slowly that I'm sure a
lot of professional photographers looked
down on my photography still but by
being that engaged and emerged in the
process as opposed to any sort of formal
structure of what makes a photograph I
innovated my own style i innovated my
own type of work that later on you know
people have introduced me to Studs
Terkel and people introduced me to you
know to these these these wonderful
photographers of the past who took these
you know Jake you know Jacob Riis and
then who took these wonderful photos of
regular people that my work you know
kind of grew to resemble but I mean any
resemblance just came out of being on
the street and doing it all day long
and just and and figuring out we know
what it was that I liked the most and
without any education of what a correct
photograph was and you know I think if
humans of New York has original elements
if humans of New York is original in any
way it was because I was just so
addicted to taking photos that I never
stopped to learn about photography and
because of that you know I I just I was
figuring out as I went along well it
seems to me also that there are many
different facets of photography one
component of which is the technical
knowledge but certainly another
component of which is choosing the
subject matter hit and thinking about
the story that an image tells so you
were learning about photography but you
were doing it visa vie the sheer volume
of experience that you were gathering
behind the camera and walking through
New York City right well I was just you
know I was looking for anyone who
anything that captured my attention or
curiosity it all got photographed I mean
and that's one of the beautiful things
about digital cameras is I mean you can
just take a thousand photos every single
day um and so you don't have to worry
about conserving film like you can just
photograph everything and so anything
that caught my eye got photographed and
then when you go home and you load your
thousand pictures on the computer and
you start going through and because you
don't know how to photograph you
photographed that person 50 different
times and you're looking at your 50
photos of each person and you're finding
the one that you think looks the best
and then you're going and you're doing
it again and you're doing it again and
suddenly you're not taking 50 photos of
each person you're taking forward even
30 then 20 and then 10 as you start to
get an idea of what it is that you think
is a great photo and what it is that you
like and that was kind of really how I
was honing in on my style again which
might still be considered primitive it
still might be considered unschooled by
a lot of people but I was just honing in
on what I liked about a photo um and
that's that was the process
what were you what were you doing with
these photos in the in the beginning or
maybe a better question is when you
first started putting photos online what
did that look like at first I was
putting that I had I'm one of my main
kind of weaknesses and blind spots in
the beginning was not understanding the
importance of daily content because you
know I never had a blog before um and so
I kind of had this great and I mean it
kind of mirrors my my journey as a
college student where I was like trying
to do something huge instead of focusing
on doing something every single day
and so I was I had this huge kind of
sweeping project of I was gonna
photograph 10,000 people and plot their
photos on a map I was dumping about 30
or 40 of these portraits every single
day onto this website that I had that
nobody was going to in the numbers I
even had a counter on the top of the
website the counting counting up to ten
thousand because that's all I cared
about was the end I was gonna get ten
thousand I was gonna create this
sweeping photography project was a hold
humans of New York at the time or what
was called it was called humans from New
York from the very beginning yes and it
things released and and nobody was
really paying attention and I was taking
hundreds and thousands of portraits and
things really started to get traction
when I started posting the photos as I
got them on the social media mainly
Facebook that is when things really
started to grow and the focus of humans
of New York moved away from this giant
sweeping project of that was going to
cover the entire city of New York and be
some sort of representation of New York
City and it switched much more to about
the individual who is this person then
I'm meeting each day and it became
something more personal and immediate
and that's when things really started
growing Brendan I'd love to ask you
about the green lady if that rings a
bell could you
please describe for folks the experience
of the green lady so I mean I'm in New
York and I've been trying to make this
work for about six months now and six
months in you know that time of my life
was probably the equivalent about two
years of work because I worked every
single day I worked on Christmas I
worked on Thanksgiving I didn't go home
all I did was photograph all day long
you know I would go out I would I would
just photograph people had come home I
would take a nap and then I would go out
at night and try to get some more photos
and so I gotten thousands of these
portraits and not many people were
paying attention I think I had just kind
of started posting my photos on Facebook
and I photographed this woman and she
was dressed all in green and she had
green hair and green makeup and I
remember it was a it was a photo that I
didn't like I thought it was a very bad
photo and I wasn't even going to really
post it on the blog but then I
remembered that she had said something
to me she had said I used to be a
different color every single day but
then one day I was green and that was a
great day and so I've been green for 15
years and I I remember thinking to
myself well I don't really like the
photograph but I'm gonna try putting
this quote above it that she said and I
posted it onto Facebook and suddenly it
was the most engaged with photo that I'd
ever posted I think we're talking like
67 likes at this time there was not a
lot of people following my page um and
it really it was kind of a Eureka moment
because it really made sense that you
know in this
during these months and almost a year of
doing nothing but approaching random
people on the street and asking for
their photograph the thing that
strangely I had gotten to be an expert
at wasn't the photography but it was the
approaching strangers and the the
walking up to random people getting
rejected a lot of times and not letting
that affect my my mood and then once
meeting somebody you know in a very
short amount of time making that person
comfortable and kind of the Eureka
moment was if that is what I've become
good at if that is what I have to offer
the world shouldn't I
now that I've gotten over this fear of
approaching a stranger use that
opportunity to learn a little bit about
this person so that I can share a little
bit about this person with other people
who might be curious of the people
around them but haven't been able to
overcome that fear of talking to
strangers and you know it turned out
that the audience for that the the
amount of people who were curious of the
lives of the people around them but were
too afraid to ask you know ended up
being hundreds then thousands and then
tens of thousands and millions and then
now tens of millions and you know from
that moment on humans of New York stops
being a photography project
I don't even view myself as a
photographer you know you can you can
write a three-page essay about why I'm a
horrible photographer and it's been done
many times and it doesn't really bother
me because I stopped viewing myself as a
photographer a long time ago the
photography is really secondary to
humans of New York you know humans have
York is my effort in a short of time as
possible to make a random person on the
street comfortable enough and seem that
and seem like somebody's interested
enough in their lives that they'll share
their story with me and they'll share
something deep and vulnerable and real
and honest about their lives so that I
can share that with millions of people
every single night and humans of New
York over the past six years has been my
effort to get as good at that as
possible this this is a perfect segue to
asking about the approaches and
questions which is which is a really
important thing I've spent the entire I
feel guilty because I spent the entire
if you look I have not posted a picture
of myself on humans of New York in years
I don't I don't do it I find I find that
humans of New York is best when I'm the
most invisible I feel that the less
humans of New York is about Brandon
Stanton the more influential humans of
New York has become so yeah it's it
feels very unnatural to have spent an
hour talking already and talk nothing
about myself so I'm gonna ask about the
work and you can you can talk about
yourself in third-person if it makes it
feel better but I will have to I will
have to involve you in this
when what do you say when you Colt
approach someone on the street assuming
that now of course you could use humans
of New York and a lot of people would
recognize it and you could break the ice
that way but with it early on when
nobody would recognize that how did you
how did you open and then what what did
you use to break the ice in the first 60
seconds first thing always
is do you mind if I take your photograph
that was the first thing and I mean
these are all little things I learned is
you don't walk up to somebody and ask do
you have a minute do you know because
that immediately puts somebody on
defensive because especially in New York
City people are walking up to you all
day long trying to sell you something
asking for money
so people are naturally very defensive
um so I don't want my goal is to get
into it as soon as possible
so people realize that this is something
a little bit different and I'm not
looking to for their money that's the
main thing you know I'm not looking for
their money um so I normally walk up and
I say do you mind if I take your
photograph
um I run a website called humans of New
York and basically what I do is over the
past several years I've photographed
about 10,000 people on the streets of
New York City and around the world and I
just learned a little bit about everyone
I photograph um and so I was just
wondering if I could take your photo and
ask you a few questions now before he
had the 10,000 and went around the world
when it was maybe the hundredth person
or 200 person was it the same pitch -
that day I was trying to give you
actually the pitch that I used to give
in the early days now I pull out my cell
phone - number one New York Times
bestselling books um you know 20 million
followers on Facebook and the whole
reason of that even though it kind of
sounds like boastful and Bragi is that
especially if somebody hasn't heard of
humans of New York you know I want to
convince them in a short amount of time
as possible that is it's something real
one that's important and that it's
something that you know is a lot of
people know about and a lot of people
follow it's not a joke it's not a prank
you're not gonna be embarrassed you're
not gonna you know my goal is in a short
amount of time as possible to kind of
you know make the person feel
comfortable and these days a big part of
that is kind of explaining how big the
block is because then it's then it's
like oh this person is not trying to
hustle me this person isn't trying to
scam me um but you know to be honest you
know in the early days my success you
know the amount of people who let me
take their photo wasn't that much less
except back then I wasn't a best-selling
author I was just a kid um you know who
was you know trying to make an art
project and and you know people wanted
to help and so you know the I think a
lot of people think that you know one of
the reasons so many people are willing
to talk to me is because humans of New
York is so well known especially in New
York now but you know I the my my rate
of people who would talk to me was not
all that different when I was just
getting started are there any other
nonverbal Oh use to that I mean there's
tons of them and but I mean again these
aren't things that I like I these aren't
things that you know I planned read
about you know it's not that I get a lot
of trial and error well they were they
they were burned into me by being
rejected so much and you know some
rejections on the streets of New York
aren't always polite you know what I
mean it was hard you know in the early
days I mean I remember there were days I
mean the hardest part about it was I
mean especially when I got started in
humans in New York didn't have any fans
and it wasn't booked it's you know it
wasn't made into any books and you know
my family didn't believe in it and my
friends thought I was crazy I had no
photography experience I'm in New York
City you know stopping random people and
asking them questions and I'm feeling
insecure and you know I when you walk up
to somebody and you ask them if they can
take your photo and they respond like
you're some sort of freak or that you're
weird you know it's it's hard to not
internalize that because you're so
insecure at the moment about you know
whether or not what you're doing is
weird
and if it's something that that you know
it am i am i weird you know for asking
these people for their for their
photographs and you know i go out some
days and ten people in a row would make
me feel like I'm some sort of freak but
do you know what city you're in you
can't be stopped and rid of people like
get out
like it won't you what are you doing
like no you can't take my photo and get
out of here you know what I mean
and like during my formative and like
impressionable you know early days when
I'm trying to figure this out you know
five reactions like that in a row when
nobody's paying attention to your work
and you've been trying for months and
you can't figure it out
I mean psychologically was very tough
and you know there'd be days where that
would happen I just couldn't do it
anymore
and I would just go home and and you
know lay in bed either
yeah yeah yeah you're right well I mean
it's just like the that was that's the
hardest part about doing it uh what what
did you what did you say I mean what
would you say to yourself during a
period like that I mean it sounds so to
me at least I mean the picture that it's
painting having experienced some dark
periods in my life that had been maybe
catalyzed by various things it sounds
really soul-crushing I mean that sounds
really no it's just that was all you
know like that was all it was all like
you know all of the doubt and you know
all those and not having any money and
you notice nobody's paying attention and
you know I'm just doing this all day
long for months and you know all the
tough [ __ ] was and like the loneliness
too like I didn't know anybody in New
York like there was like I knew like two
people and cuz and you know there was a
Christmas break where those two people
went home and like for two weeks I
didn't see anybody that I knew Jesus
yeah and you know I remember I you know
it's I spent Christmas Eve alone and
diner
um and then I just went out and
photographed you know it's like because
just like the only thing it was the only
thing that could like that would keep me
from like thinking about how like
unlikely it was and Nina weather how a
stupid an idea it might be um like the
only thing that that I think you know
kept me from thinking about the
possibility of failing was doing it it
was just photographing and so like
whenever I started to think is this
gonna work is it not gonna work I just
go out and photograph you know like that
was my only way of like keeping those
Wolves away you know is this ultimately
going to be a success am I wasting my
time am I am I am i stupid like the only
way to keep those away was to go out and
work and you know and so that's what I
would do just all day long and do it and
do it and do it and so like these
negative things like the rejection of
people and you know people saying no and
then I was talking about like all of the
negative stuff like the thing that was
like counteracting that all the time was
just loving it so much you know I just I
just I just loved it so much and so yeah
you know it's like it was just kind of
this this the same way I was obsessed
with markets you know I was obsessed
with taking photos and so that's kind of
what carried me through it all I mean
listening to this story it makes me want
to ask you when I look at humans in New
York and think about how many thousands
of people you've humiliated traveling to
other countries helping to paint a more
complete picture of humanity instead of
allowing
mass-media distortion to create
us-versus-them mentality or
counteracting that at least to a very
real degree in helping millions of
people who have been exposed to your
work and the interviews to feel less
alone I mean are you that's a huge
[ __ ] deal and I'm it just it pains me
to hear a story like this but it's so
helpful for you to share it because I
wonder how many people have ended up
like in that diner alone and just quit
right they just stop and that well I
mean it's not even it's not even about
stopping you know it's just like that's
I think humans of New York work it's not
about like goals or early mission or you
know I had a goal and I had a mission
but people just feel alone period you
know what I mean it's like that's that's
why humans in New York has succeeded and
I'm not even talking about the people
reading it I mean the the number one
question that people ask me is how do
you get people to share with you and you
know I think you know for for most
people and they're not just if you
follow humans of New York you know like
I was yesterday I was talking with a
woman who I mean she had not heard of
humans in New York this is a perfect
example you know I I she was catching a
train she had 30 minutes she had never
heard of humans of New York we start out
with me kind of showing her the blog and
30 minutes later the place that we ended
up at was she was in this purgatory
where her husband was depressed and an
alcoholic and he wasn't doing anything
that was ultimately so bad he didn't
beat her he didn't cheat on her but she
wasn't getting fulfilled and she was
wondering if she was living her best
life by staying with him for the kids
and she came to this place where she
admitted that she was kind of secretly
hoping that he would do something bad to
make the decision easier on her and like
that's sort of like honesty and that
sort of truth and that sort of rawness I
mean I don't know if she even admitted
that to herself before and you know
people ask me and that happens all the
time to him like that's good humans of
New York I mean some of it's just you
know pictures of kids saying cute stuff
and some of its cute couples you know
talking about their relationship but you
know good good humans of New York is is
when we get to that moment you know when
me and somebody are thinking through
something or talking through something
that they might not have thought through
before and you know the way people say
how do you get there with a complete
stranger you know I think that whenever
I'm talking to somebody on the street
there are two threads running through
their head at any given time and one of
them is this kind of fear of being
exposed this feeling of being vulnerable
and discomfort who is this guy like why
is he asking me through these questions
and on the other hand there is this
appreciation of being heard that even
though I don't know this guy this is the
first person who has taken such a
focused and detailed interest in my
problems and and and the the feeling of
having somebody focused so intensely not
on the sports teams you like or the
music you like or any of the other kind
of trivial things that we we we got we
get asked it on it on a daily basis but
you know these these real things that
you're struggling with and maybe not
even on the top of your mind but like in
the back of your mind that you're not
even really bringing to the surface you
know
being heard like that is such a
validating thing that that's why people
always share and I tell people at the
beginning of every interview that these
questions are going to be hard and
anything you don't want to answer you
don't have to answer and we talked about
when they got molested as a child we
talked about them cheating on their
husbands we talked about their
alcoholism we talked about how they
don't love their child as much as they
expected they would you know we talked
about all these things and almost never
do people say I don't want to talk about
that I don't want to talk about that
and I think the reason humans of New
York works isn't because the people who
are reading it feel alone that's a big
part of it is that people when they see
somebody being vulnerable in a way that
they're afraid to be vulnerable
themselves they connect with that person
but it really works because the people
on the street that I meet are so
thankful to have somebody really listen
to them that in that bubble and an hour
and a half where I'm sitting with a
stranger on the street this magic
happens where they're willing to kind of
let me into a space in their mind or
their soul or whatever it is that they
don't really let other people into and
it's it's that place that I think
connects with so many people that's an
incredible gift / talent that you've
developed that allows you to make people
comfortable enough to open up to that
extent in 30 minutes I mean that is
incredibly impressive to me even given
the fact that perhaps one of the
elements underpinning it is how how
heard they feel which is absolutely I'm
sure the case I think about questions a
lot and you have much more experience
than I do and that just blows me away
that you're able to get there in such a
short period of time
what are some of the other ingredients
or aspects of it that help you to
questions perhaps that have wanted to
get hit it's it's not the questions I
have about three or four entry questions
that I use what's your biggest struggle
how is your life turned out differently
than you expected it to what do you feel
most guilty about but really the planned
questions are just kind of springboards
into a conversation and you know where
how you get to that deep place with a
person is absolute presence it's being
100% there
you're not thinking in the framework of
an interview you're not looking at a
list of questions you're not thinking
about your next question you're not
thinking about how this person fits into
your idea of them and what you know
about them
you're 100% there and you're 100%
listening to them and your questions are
100% coming based on curiosity about
what they are telling you and nothing
else
and you know why it is that I think
humans if New York is special and I
think humans of New York is is something
that you know is precious and and maybe
difficult to replicate is that you know
I've spent seven years in these
conversations with 10,000 people and
it's not necessarily that I have gotten
so good at asking questions it's just
that I have gotten so comfortable in the
presence of a stranger and so
comfortable in the presence of somebody
that I've just met that I can sit there
with them without an ounce of
self-consciousness and just be and just
be there with it and listen to them and
be curious about them and there's this
energy that happens there that this
doesn't feel like somebody that's
interviewing you it feels like somebody
who knows you and cares about you
is really interested in what's going on
in your life and I and it's it's very
subtle and hard to describe but I think
it's that energy and that presence and
that being there and it's something I
had to earn it's the same thing like
public speaking you know I when do you
really good good at public speaking it's
when you've done it so much that you can
be yourself on the stage yet and there's
only one way to get there and that's to
be onstage scared as [ __ ] over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over again and I think the only way to
get to that place where you can have
that rapport with a stranger is not by
studying interview techniques it's by
sitting with thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of strangers
until nothing feels strange about it
anymore and you're able to be in that
calm present place and what happens is
your energy transfers to the other
person and they get to that place - if
we were to pick up the example that you
gave just a few minutes ago about this
woman talking about her relationship
with her husband and his depression and
alcoholism and so on how did you if you
remember how did you end up there in in
other words do you recall how the
conversation headed to that - that oh
yeah I mean it can well let me give you
another example since I already uh let
me give me an example of somebody I
talked to in the Philippines
a few weeks ago same thing I've traveled
to 30 different countries now I've done
the exact same work I've been to
Pakistan have been to Iran I've been to
Iraq and I work with interpreters and
the process is exactly the same I just
walk up to people random people and get
into these conversations with them there
was a woman in a park in the Philippines
and I started asking her I think one of
the first questions I asked her was what
is your biggest goal in life and she
said she wanted to
have a good family life and so I thought
that that was the story and I started
asking about that and I learned that she
wanted to have a good family life
because when she was young her family
split and she was forced to go to the
courthouse with her mom and her dad at
the age of nine and the judge made her
choose which parent she wanted to go
with and so I thought that was the story
and so I started asking questions about
that and then I learned that she ended
up going with her mom and afterwards she
her mom remarried and she didn't like
her new stepfather so she ran away and I
thought that that was the story so I
started asking questions about that and
then I found out that the reason she ran
away was because her stepfather was
abusing her and that she had never told
a person in her life including her mom
until that moment that that had happened
and that's how we end up in those places
is I just I am just curious about what's
going on in there you know I'm just
curious about what happened I want to
know the story and I just asked and I
asked and I asked and and if something's
not quite making sense I I want to know
why and so I asked more and I asked more
it and it's it's like you can't I mean
somebody can choose to eventually to not
tell the truth by saying I'm
uncomfortable with it but it can't
really be concealed if somebody is
really really really really curious you
know what I mean you can never you know
get to the point like it's humans of New
York interviews don't work I always say
it's not because somebody doesn't have
an interesting story humans of New York
interviews don't work when I reach a
place when somebody's uncomfortable with
the process which is absolutely fine
there's that's completely understandable
I'm a random person
I'm sharing these stories with 20
million people it's 100 percent fine if
you don't want to share like that's not
that is that is nothing against you at
all but those are the interviews that
don't make it on the blog it's not that
people aren't interesting it's that
humans of New York really kind of
thrives on this kind of honesty and if
somebody's willing to be honest I mean
everybody's got an interesting story and
so it's like the eye hit dead ends not
because somebody's boring it's because
somebody isn't comfortable with
disclosing um and so that's that's kind
of what defines you know the the humans
of New York interviewer or what is
usable the humans of New York interview
how often when people disclose when they
do go there and disclose these very
vulnerable stories or things they have
never told anyone else how often do they
ask that you not use it or that they're
or express concern that it's gonna cause
some type of problem for them well
that's that's one thing that I am very
principled about I give the person
agency every step of the way I tell them
anything you don't want to ant first of
all they don't have to talk to me okay
they have that decision once we start
talking I say any question you don't
want to answer you don't have to answer
if you tell me something during the
course of this interview and you change
your mind afterwards and don't want me
to share it that's fine at the end of
the interview if you would like me to
photograph your hands or your feet
instead of your face we can do that in
fact if it's a very vulnerable story I
will normally insist on that to protect
the person or protect somebody that
they're talking about
if after I've done the interview and
before it's posted at any time you
change your mind and you don't want me
to share it
I give them my email address and after
the photo is up for any reason at any
time if you become uncomfortable from
all the attention and would like me to
take the story down
I immediately will and so people have
control of it every step of the way
it's very important to me that you
nobody ever sees humans of New York as
something that was done to them I always
want it to be seen as something that was
done with them and you know how I failed
at that sometimes out of the 10,000
people have I interviewed you know have
there been people who were didn't expect
me to share a certain part of their
story or was surprised by it or it was a
negative experience for there have been
a handful you know but I can only say
that those are the those are the worst
moments for me when humans in New York
was a negative experience for somebody
because that's who I really care about
is the people that that are on the blog
you know because I mean they're the
they're the people who kind of had that
moment with you know I spent an hour and
a half with them and we and we got to
that place and you know I I just if they
are hurt by it you know what I mean
or if it's like it's especially if they
were really kind of vulnerable than
that's that's when I feel the worst
about myself because I know how much
pressure that spotlight can be and I
know you know how how difficult it can
be you know under you having 20 million
people look at you and so you know if I
ever feel that like I may be
accidentally misrepresented it or you
know or that that's that's when I feel
the worst how do you think about money
as it relates to humans of New York
ostensibly you want to probably eat more
than peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
and eggs now at the same yet it's no I'm
just gonna say in terms of what you do
with advertising or partnerships or
projects because you have such also such
sensitive not not always but a
you have such potentially sensitive
subject matter and it's so personalized
for these folks variety kisses how do
you how do you think about that right
well the you know right obviously so
humans in New York I think we sold a
million and a half books um the you know
the the television show you know
Facebook you know in Facebook there was
a more than one person interested in it
and Facebook you know they they they
compensated me well for the four years
of work that I worked on the television
series so you know I'm very comfortable
right now you know I mean humans of New
York has made me a let's just say I'm
not working about worrying about peanut
butter and sandwiches with that being
said uh I will say that humans of New
York has raised mmm I've made I've made
a fraction of the money with humans of
New York that we have raised for charity
a small fraction of the money that we've
raised for charity
um I have turned down maybe more money
than I've made from people who want to
use my brand to partner with their brand
you know um big brands have offered me a
lot of money to do humans of and I'm
just gonna make up some names you know
what I mean like humans of mercedes-benz
humans of you know humans of China
sponsored by Virgin Airlines these are
all fake things and I'm making up right
now but had resembled offers that have
been made to me um where where I make
the dividing line is that I'm willing to
make money as Brandon Stanton a big part
of my income comes from speeches you
know I give about ten of these a year um
and on that is a big
part of my income I have sell books as
Brandon Stanton
um I don't sell the name humans of New
York to anyone
I don't rent my brand to anyone um and
because I never want any piece of
content that I share to have a single
motive I've never broken that seal and
you know it's been it's been so tempting
but I just know if I break it once I'm
never going to get it back um so I for
seven years I've never been compensated
for a piece of content that I've posted
on my blog uh and you know that is that
is the main delineation um then I make
between you know what can be monetized
and what can't and because of that like
I said I'm not worrying about peanut
butter and sandwiches anymore um but you
know there is there is a little bit of
an insecurity am I gonna look back in 40
years of everything suddenly everything
suddenly goes away and Facebook and
Instagram nobody are using anymore am I
gonna be like oh man I'm working the
night shift now I had 20 million
followers 20 years ago maybe I should
have tried a little harder to make some
money but that's how I view it now
should have done those humans in New
York lunch boxes while I had the chance
there you go so you mentioned the book
I'd like to chat about that for for a
second because it's it's been the books
at this point certainly but the at least
as I understand it the first book so
millions of copies certainly more than a
million was it easy to find a publisher
for that first book the Macmillan God
blessed them so I got the time you know
I I think when I sold the book I had a
few hundred thousand Facebook fans and
it was growing so fast you know there
was so much energy you know things were
really taking off and I just thought
oh my gosh you know everybody's gonna
want to publish this book and there's
six big publishers I'm sure you know all
this um or seven or something like that
and you you the goal is to get all of
them interested um and so and then you
know in the perfect world all of them
are interested and then they bid against
each other right and so I only three of
them would meet with me or four of them
maybe um and during those meetings I
thought that I killed it you know I
thought oh man like then I described it
so well I you know presented so well
they're all going to be very interested
and so we had an auction and the the
bids were due by 12 o'clock noon on one
day and it's like at 11 o'clock I hadn't
heard anything from my agent and I was
just like what's going on so I texted
him oh the first three dropped out
there's they didn't make it offer
there's still one that we haven't heard
from yet uh and I'm just like oh my god
you know because that book was well that
book was my life raft cuz I didn't have
any money at that time was hoping to get
a little bit of a book deal so I could
you know pay my bills and I just
remember I went to the YMCA and I just
ran like five miles cuz I thought it was
gonna be the worst day of my life and
then when I got on the treadmill I found
out that Macmillan had made a a a small
but respectable offer and that's how I
got a book deal by the skin of my teeth
which I think was uh which was lucrative
for all parties involved and what were
some of the reasons for not meeting with
you or not putting an offer that they
gave because there's two types of books
that have a history of not selling well
well there's a lot of types but mine
mine fit two categories it was a
photography book
photography's books don't sell based on
conventional wisdom and it was a what
they viewed as a regional book
where it is a photography book since it
centered on a single city
therefore nobody's going to want it that
was the that was that was the argument
against publishing humans of New York
oops this is I love these stories
because they are the rule and not the
exception for so many things that turn
into something well things that are not
derivative you know what I mean like in
my mind in my mind like the most
valuable idea is the one that nobody's
ever seen before like that's when you've
got the gold but you've got a better
chance of just choosing something else
that's good and making something
derivative on it because then when you
go when you go into these places and you
pitch you can say oh this is the this is
fifty shades of gray but you know with
furries it's like it's it's it's funny
that like for me as an artist and as a
creator the the last thing I ever want
to do is be describing my work as it's
this but with a twist you know what I
mean like I I want to be creating
something new however in the marketplace
the things that are have most likely
chance of getting bought are things that
people can can peg to other past
successes and so when you walk in with
something like what I thought was humans
of New York's greatest value which was
there really wasn't anything else like
it at the time yeah but what are the
comparables you're like ah that's the
whole point their [ __ ] word I just
think the same thing you know when I was
making the television series it's like
the same thing it's like as an artist I
want this to be like nothing else that's
been that's like the only thing I care
about is making something that's really
unlike anything else like that that
if it's like something else it's it's I
don't really want to obsess over it for
three years trying to make it you know
my goal is to is to make something new
and something fresh and when you're
trying to get compensated for your work
you know the thing that you care about
the most as an artist is often the thing
that's held against you the most because
people are risk averse and they want to
see something comparable that has also
done well what's next for you maybe if
you do you have five-year plans
three-year plans and so on at this point
or is it still 24 hours by 24 hours
what's next for you I do I'm having a
baby
that's congratulations that's a big
thing you know having a baby in July so
beyond that the like for me right now
the biggest kind of artistic tension um
is knowing because of my experience on
social media um the past seven years
knowing knowing how social media works
knowing the importance of output and
content and daily content and and
engagement and things like that knowing
how to build an audience on one hand and
wanting to push myself as an artist on
the other hand and you know what I
really want to do as an artist is I kind
of want to withdraw from the daily you
know output model I want to work on
things that have longer time frames that
are more polished and or maybe longer
but take longer to produce and and more
resources but that in order to do that
that requires me to kind of pull back
from the blog um which you know the the
golden rule of you know social media is
keep engaging with your audience keep
connecting with your
audience you know don't lose touch don't
lose touch don't lose touch but the
artist in me wants to go disappear for a
while and you know go into a dark cave
and and come out with something so I
think you know that is that is the main
push and pull in my mind right now so
I'm gonna be going to the Philippines
next month to work on I'm gonna spend a
month filming a documentary on somebody
cuz I love documentaries and I want to
make a documentary that is very
interesting so that might not be what's
best for business or best for growing
audience or best you know by social
media metrics but that is that is what
is exciting to me and it all comes back
to that moment it's like I it's so funny
and I think you're probably the same way
is that we have these mantras and these
things that we've learned that we stand
on stage and we and we say and we and we
think about you know don't wait for the
perfect idea you know it's never gonna
seem perfect you just got to go after it
choose you know what is nourishing and
the moment things like that and if
you're like me like I have to I have to
preach to myself you know a lot you know
and tell myself the same thing that I'm
telling other people because it's so
easy to kind of you know fall back into
what everybody else is struggling with
as well because you never truly escape
it and so you know one of the things
that I do is you know I go back to that
moment when I lost my job and I was
walking in Chicago and I asked myself
you know if nothing mattered but but how
I was spending my time you know what
what would I see what would I be doing
what would be most nourishing for me in
any given moment if it was if nothing
else mattered except for how I spent my
time and you know I'm trying to remind
myself of that you know the same thing I
tell other people and right now I want
to go to the Philippines I want to make
a documentary and it might not be best
for business and it might not even be
best for Hemans of New York but it's
bread and once - and so that is uh that
is a North Star that I'm trying to
follow good for you and then I'm excited
for you to disappear for a little while
that may come off the wrong way but you
get the sentiment behind it and I have a
random suggestion okay which is if you
have not read crypto nomicon which is a
book by Neal Stephenson also wrote Snow
Crash crypto nomicon part of the through
line one of the narratives takes place
in the Philippines so that could be that
could be fun to pick up but Brendan
thank you so much for taking the time
today this was really a wonderful
experience for me and thank you for
being vulnerable also and
I'd be telling filling in some of the
color in the the story of your life thus
far and it's been it's been really nice
to get to know you a little better in
this conversation well thank you so much
hope some of that's usable yeah I think
it is is there anything else you would
like to ask if people suggest to people
any any closing comments before we wrap
up all right awesome
well once again really appreciate you
making the time yeah particularly how
much you think about how you spend your
time to chat with me and with everybody
today
and for everyone listening you can as
always find links to everything that we
have spoken about to all of Brandon's
projects as well in the show notes at
tim dot blog forward slash podcast and
until next time do what is nourishing
for you in the moment or at least ponder
the question and thanks for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell that out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy this
episode is brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec
if you're a longtime listener of the
show or a brand new to the podcast my
favorite Finnish entrepreneurs who
founded this company of course I don't
know that many Finnish entrepreneurs but
they may be my favorites have something
new that I've been loving and some of
you are familiar with for sig Matic I've
used their products for years now they
were introduced to me by an acrobat of
all folks and they tend to mix different
types of medicinal mushrooms into their
products I have recently started using
their matcha which is a green tea which
is designed as a coffee alternative and
if you're trying to cut back on caffeine
as I am these days the matcha is a great
option and one that I originally learned
to love in Japan has a very smooth
texture to it they're macho blend in
particular includes the amino acid
dolphin theanine which helps to provide
a let's call it balance boost of energy
without the jitters it also includes the
adaptogen astrologists from pronouncing
that correctly which may help with
overall stress
tolerance and for those of you who are
wondering know the products don't taste
like mushrooms if they say mushroom
coffee for instance another product that
I use doesn't taste like mushrooms it
tastes like coffee but you get the
nutritional benefits of some of these
special ingredients so the products
don't taste like mushrooms and are
enjoyable I offer them to my houseguests
and use them myself
and I don't particularly want to drink
anything that tastes like mushrooms
so moving on the folks at Forsyth matic
have designed a few special deals for
you guys my listeners which include many
of my favorite products of theirs so
check it out visit for sig Matic fo you
are SI g ma TI c comp org slash tim-tim
that's t IMT IM no space to see these
special deals which are not offered
anywhere else remember to use the code
Tim Tim I don't know why they just temp
them but there we go remember to use the
code Tim Tim a check out to receive your
special discount again that's for sig
Matic comm forward slash Tim Tim and
enter the promo code
Tim Tim check it out this episode is
brought to you by wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site tim vlog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors all enormous
calm and the founder is matt mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times
just search matt mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog the business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
WordPress calm and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce at 5:38 TechCrunch heads
CNN and time just to name a handful
and one of my friends at Google she'll
remain nameless has told me that
WordPress comm offers deep for best
out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable and close it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
let's perhaps the best part WordPress
comm guide you through the entire
experience they have hundreds of designs
and templates that you can use and it's
easy to get started there's no need to
worry about security upgrades posting
any of that down for 24/7 support and
they're very very responsive questions
they can read back to you and this
allows you to create the highest quality
with the least amount of headache and
friction so if you're building a website
for Harriet my friends come to me and
ask what I use what I recommend they use
the answer is wordpress.com so check it
out if you want to get started today
learn more with a 15% discount off any
new plan go to wordpress.com forward
slash Tim create your website and find
the plans right for you it's a little
more take a look wordpress.com 4/10 15%
off it ran new website check it out